what happened to the heroes of the
predator movies why are predators so
attracted to heat what's the reasoning
behind their methods watch for even more
questions we may never know the answers
to
to date no character human or otherwise
has been featured in more than one film
in the predator franchise the lack of
any recurring characters is one of the
franchise's strengths but it does leave
one curious as to how each human moves
on with their life after surviving the
yacht-jaw each sequel has attempted to
have schwarzenegger reprise his role as
alan dutch schaefer but he's refused
leaving the character's fate hazy for
decades in 2020 arnold gave in for the
2020 video game predator hunting grounds
this game includes audio journals
accounting for dutch's actions between
1987 and the games 2025 setting
according to the journals dutch has been
traveling the world searching for more
evidence of the yacht jaws presence on
earth he teams up with the other worldly
life forms program the shady government
agency from predator 2. as the earth
gets hotter predators visit frequently
leading to repeated battles between
dutch and the yacht jaw by 2025 he's
been rebuilt using yacht jaw tech
fearless and fit despite his advanced
age this thing is haunting us
all of us
across the predator franchise the
yacht-jaw have demonstrated a common
modus operandi that includes a few
signature kills no predator film would
be complete for instance without someone
having their skull and spine ripped out
of their bodies in one swift motion the
yacht-jaw removes skulls and spines to
display them as trophies and add bones
to their armor to show off their killing
powers their reasoning behind flaying a
victim and leaving their bodies behind
however is a little more murky the
intention behind hanging their skin prey
is still the subject of debate among
fans the yajja do not appear to collect
the skins they remove from their victims
so it's clearly the bodies themselves
that are important to the ritual it's
likely that these bodies are left as a
form of intimidation to throw their next
opponents off balance there's also a
theory that only those considered easy
prey are flayed as they are unworthy of
having their bones collected as trophies
not only did i kill this guy this action
says according to this theory but i even
had time to rip his skin off afterwards
if you don't want the same thing to
happen to you you'd better be more
entertaining
in predator rebel ana tells the
mercenaries that their stalker matches
the description of quote the demon who
makes trophies of man from local
folklore the stalkers are said to only
appear during the hottest summers when
the yacht jar returned to earth in
predator 2 it's during a record-breaking
heat wave in l.a predator hunting
grounds implies that climate change has
made the earth a more attractive place
to hunt the natural assumption to make
is that the heat mirrors that of the
yacht jaw's natural habitat and that a
hot summer is the time during which the
earth is most habitable for both humans
and yaja as the series progresses the
yajja's preference and climate is less
emphasized alien vs predator reveals
some yacht-jaw visit every 100 years in
antarctica furthermore aliens vs
predator requiem is set in colorado and
the story is explicitly set near
halloween in the predator this doesn't
mean that the predators don't still
prefer the heat but it does remove its
necessity
in predator 2 mike harrigan discovers an
alien hunter nicknamed city hunter by
fans has been on an undercover killing
spree the film concludes with harrigan
chasing the predator to his ship and
killing him however other yachts have
been watching all of this unfold hidden
by cloaking technology they retrieve the
dead predator's body and leave la out of
this group of yacht jaw only one is seen
making kills it's unclear if the others
simply haven't been caught remain on the
ship the entire time or if they are here
on other business only one member of the
los angeles hunting party their leader
greyback ever appears again in the
predator expanded universe and that
story does not account for his
whereabouts during predator 2. you can't
see the eyes of the demon
[Music]
at the end of predator 2 harrigan
receives a trophy from the yacht jaw
leader for killing the city hunter it's
a flintlock pistol labeled rafael
adelini
this gift is evidence that the yacha
have been hunting on earth for centuries
the 1996 comic predator 1718 depicts the
original encounter between the yacht jaw
known as greyback and pirate captain
rafael aldolini adelini a criminal with
a righteous moral compass wants to
return a chest of gold to the church
from which it was stolen his crew
objects and mutinies grayback
surprisingly joins adelini and together
they defeat his traitorous crew attolini
is lethally injured and offers gray back
his pistol as a tribute
the protagonist of alien vs predator is
lex woods an expert ice climber hired to
guide an expedition to explore an
ancient temple beneath an antarctic
island lex survives being picked off by
the xenomorphs and yacht-jaw and allies
herself with the yacht-jaw hunter scar
she receives a yacht-jaw combi stick
weapon as a trophy and much of her fate
after the yacht-jaw craft departs is
unknown lex's arc hasn't been revisited
or referenced in any expanded universe
material however there is a piece of
evidence that lex or at least her
weapons were recovered from the
antarctic battle site
in 2018's the predator dr casey brackett
explores project stargazer's
headquarters and finds a case containing
lexus spear this seems to confirm that
alien vs predator is still part of the
predator cannon
the action of alien vs predator takes
place inside an ancient temple in
antarctica the site of a ritual where
adolescent yacht job proved themselves
against the universe's ultimate killing
machines inside the temple lies an
enslaved xenomorph queen kept in
hibernation for a century at a time a
few hours before a hunt she's forced to
lay eggs so that the yacht-jaw will have
something to test themselves against in
2004's ritual the queen gets wise and
instructs her children to set her free
by melting her chains with their acidic
blood at the film's climax the queen
escapes the temple into the abandoned
town and battles on the ice with lex and
scar the last human in yacht-jaw they
successfully chain her to a heavy iron
vat and push it into the freezing water
the queen drops to the bottom of the sea
and is presumably no longer a threat
other films in the alien series have
shown that xenomorphs are capable of
enduring the freezing airless vacuum of
space it is likely the queen could
survive these conditions for a while or
even forever nevertheless the antarctic
queen has never reappeared in the
franchise's canon
aliens vs predator requiem picks up
where the first avp leaves off with a
xenomorph chest burster emerging from
scars corpse this xenomorph has taken on
many of the traits of its yacht jaw host
to become the even deadlier pred alien
when the predalian crash lands a
spacecraft loaded with xenomorph eggs in
colorado another predator wolf is set
loose to clean up the mess wolf battles
with the predalien and a horde of
xenomorphs but this battle is moot the
story ends with the us government
dropping a nuke on the village
destroying almost all evidence of the
conflict in the final scene u.s army
colonel stevens presents miss yutani
with a plasma pistol fashioned by wolf
yutani seems to have plans for the
pistol that are quote not for this world
it's implied that yutani plans to
reverse engineer the technology to
advance her company's interest in space
leading to the weyland-yutani
corporation's dominance of space freight
and xenomorph experimentation in the
alien series requiem doesn't have a
sequel so we don't have many details on
what will happen next also the release
of prometheus in 2012 detached the alien
franchise from the continuity of avp
leaving the future of the yutani
corporation uncertain
2010's predators takes the action off
earth entirely and follows a group of
humans who are each abducted and
transported to a planet that is a
massive game preserve each of the human
captives is a predator in their own
right a soldier a convict a gangster and
so on but most of them are no match for
their pursuers who are bigger and badder
than any yacha seen previously they are
picked off one by one until the only
survivors are american mercenary royce
and idf sniper isabel predators ends
with isabel and royce victorious over
their hunters but still stranded on the
planet where another hunting season is
about to begin unlike most protagonists
in the predator franchise isabelle and
royce received a follow-up story
immediately in the form of an official
sequel comic 2010's predators preserve
the game the one-shot comic picks up two
months after the film as royce and
isabel continued to pick off predators
and salvage their gear the yaja
determined royce is a worthy opponent
and gift him his own set of predator
armor to wear in one-on-one battles
against a four-armed super yacht-jaw but
royce learns to depend on someone else
for a change and sets himself up as bait
so that isabelle can get the kill they
remain trapped on the planet waiting for
an opportunity to hijack a starship
in the predator another yacht-jaw comes
to earth but this time he's not here to
hunt he's on the run from the larger
genetically enhanced upgrade predator
the fugitive crash lands in mexico but
not before ejecting a pod containing
some precious cargo by the end of the
film both predators are dead with the
help of young linguistics genius rory
mckenna u.s military scientists are able
to determine that the rebel predator
came to earth to deliver the humans a
weapon a powered suit of armor called
the predator killer rory's father army
ranger quinn mckenna plans to wear it in
battle next time the yacht job come
calling but why did the fugitive
predator decide to give this weapon to
humanity in the first place does it have
anything to do with the human dna found
in his blood if he's here to help us
he's got a funny way of showing it as he
kills nearly every person he sees during
his time on our planet his apparently
benevolent intentions are only revealed
in the final scene of the film a teaser
for a sequel that has never happened
this last minute twist may be the result
of the film's reshoots which reportedly
changed a great deal of the film's
overall plot in fact in one of the three
filmed endings the fugitive's cargo pod
contains ellen ripley heroine of the
alien films
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
predator are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]